[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster
man it feels good to finally say those
words again after almost two years of
almost not playing this game definitely
not making any videos about it and don't
worry i'm not going to dwell too much on
the reason for this long hiatus and also
don't worry it's nothing horrible and
i'm doing fine
um there just have been many smaller
reasons that all stack together into me
not playing planet coaster very much or
video games in general
and i'll go into that later in the video
but first i just want to talk about this
coaster that i'm building
because it's
part of the reason that i also got back
into the game is because i just had an
idea that
was itching somewhere at the back of my
head and i really wanted to give this
thing a good try and do something with
it because for the longest time i've
been trying to come up with something
that is
well completely new that i haven't tried
to build myself before but i also
haven't seen anybody else build and of
course obviously
i'm somewhat in touch with most of the
planet coast community and i watch many
youtube videos
even when i'm not playing the game um
but you know i might not know everything
that everybody's doing so maybe some
people have had this idea before me and
i'm just unaware of it but i had this
idea that i really wanted to give a try
and
i was really inspired to work on and
it just tends to be that that's usually
for me at least the best motivation to
get into the game and put lots of hours
in and also get a little bit addicted to
see your ideas become reality because
it's just so cool to try and translate
your fantasies into the game and just
the the feeling that that gives whenever
it works out somehow
that's that's i think a huge reason why
i love playing this game but i keep
going very off-topic in tensions so i
had this idea that i really wanted to
try out and it's to do something serious
with the sns free fly coaster
because i think it's a super
under-utilized coaster not just in the
game but in real life as well there's
only one of these in real life it's
called trondon and it's in a swedish
park called scara summerland
it's
not a very big park it's not super close
to a very big city in sweden either it's
kind of out there um but i've had the
pleasure to go there on a road trip a
few years ago and that coaster really
took me by surprise honestly um because
this coaster type is designed as a
family coaster it's quite gentle it
doesn't do huge scary minervas doesn't
reach very high speeds definitely no
high g forces or anything
but it's a really unique ride experience
all thanks to that vehicle which you see
you've got the bird sitting on top of
the track and then you've got the wings
uh holding some
i don't even know what to call them some
things that you sit inside in rows of
four people and you're i say rose but
it's more like a column because you're
sitting behind and in front of each
other not next to each other um so
you're all sitting in a line there
and it's one of the most free
feeling coasters that i've ever been on
i don't know how else to describe it but
you've got nothing to the left of you
you got no you got nothing to the right
of you you can wave your arms in the air
while you're soaring through the sky and
um
i think one of the the scariest things
about it is that it's you're very out in
the open the vehicles that you're
sitting in
are not very large like quite small or
very low they only come up just above
your knees you've got a small lap bar on
your lap obviously but that aside you're
kind of just
flying and it almost feels like you're
prone to flying out of that carriage
whenever you sit in these things so
maybe that's just me being scary pants
but i thought these things were
more scary than i anticipated beforehand
and i was writing this like man this is
a family ride this is actually quite
exhilarating for a family ride so
i think these things are very underrated
in real life but also in planet coaster
hardly anybody builds these things
and in real life i know the reasons why
these things tend to not get built and i
think the biggest reason is capacity
these things have a very low capacity
sitting only
or seating only eight people per
carriage
and you know these are not coasters that
you can make long trains out of um
it's got a layout that makes it more
difficult than let's say wild mouse
coasters to incorporate lots of block
break sections in it so you know upping
the capacity with lots of block sections
is also going to be difficult
and on top of that i
think you just don't have the economies
of scale with this kind of coaster it's
a very rare coaster which means
getting the parts is probably difficult
it's um it's a huge innovation but that
also means it's probably an investment
risk to any parks looking to buy these
kinds of things so i understand why this
thing
um never became very popular in real
life but i don't think that has anything
to do with the ride experience because
the rhine experience is amazing
at least in my personal view and you
know taking into consideration that it's
a family coaster this thing is not
anywhere near my top 10 favorite
coasters in the world but it is one of
the coasters that really positively
surprised me when i wrote it in terms of
how fun it was
and in planet coaster
i don't know capacity is not the issue
but i think it might just be that these
coasters are rare that most people don't
know exactly what to do with it and it's
very hard to fit into a park it's very
hard to give this thing a theming
it's hard to come up with creative
layouts that do something new other than
just twists and turns and some inline
twists here and there
so they tend to not be the most
interesting courses to build either even
though their real life experience is
very interesting
now to all of these problems
i think i uh i have some solutions first
and foremost um the capacity
this might sound really stupid but
you know how in fantasia land you have
winged sphere and force both are
spinning coasters with not a very high
capacity but you've got two of them and
having a dueling coaster kind of doubles
the capacity of the coaster and
obviously some people are going to
rewrite both sides but that's all just
more people that are going to stand in
line and actually you know up the actual
capacity of the coaster so
basically i think that's a decent trick
to use
and for this coaster i went ahead and
did some calculations so let's say you
need 13 to 15 seconds approximately to
load people into the train and load
people out of the train at the station
assuming that you have a separate
loading and unloading station that means
that in the game you can dispatch trains
every 22 to 25 seconds which means 140
to 160 dispatches an hour let's say
approximately 150 which would mean a
thousand two hundred hourly capacity per
side and for comparison tran in scara
summerland gets 900 people per hour at
maximum
but that doesn't have a separate loading
and unloading station and that's in a
small local swedish park
i'd like to think that big chains like
disney and universal would be able to
come up with a more efficient loading
unloading system in a station
now altogether combining the two halves
of this coaster we get 2 400 guests per
hour that can ride this ride which is
fairly decent if you look for instant at
crush coaster in disneyland paris
that only manages to uh to
well right see it's
850 people per hour which is a very few
it's also too few for the park you can
definitely tell by the queue but this
ride is comparatively doing much better
so
that's that's definitely part of the
reason and secondly
when you're dueling these coasters
you can do so many more interesting
maneuvers and things that you can't do
with any other kind of dueling coaster
and this is something that you'll see
come into play later on um but for
instance you just told me built that
element where the the two tracks are
kind of back to back you've got one
track that is right side up and one
trick that is upside down and they kind
of do that twist together it's a little
bit like a zero g roll that's something
you can never ever do with any other
type of coaster maybe with a 4d coaster
or something of that sort but even then
the interaction that you have with the
other trains as you see people you know
flying twisting along with you either
below you or above you that's a kind of
interaction that you cannot get on any
other type of doodling coaster and i
think it's a part of the reason why i
really wanted to give this coaster a try
to just
come up with a whole new coaster
experience that doesn't exist anywhere
else in life and maybe this is also what
kept me really motivated to work on this
project because for me at least
there is nothing more fun than trying to
come up with a completely new concept
and seeing how you can make it work and
at every turn when you're working on
different parts of the coaster you start
seeing these new options and things that
you've never seen on a coaster before
and that's really fun
and um
it might not be the most realistic or
well
money-making way to go around building
coasters but this is a video game why
should i be too critical of that um so
that's the the whole appeal of this ride
for now i've worked on the start of the
layout but i'm going to finish the
layout
at the other sections at least in other
episodes because i am trying to come up
with this layout along with a theme and
theming the layout also based on how i
want these two parts of the coaster
experience to work together so for the
layout that i've built so far i also
have ideas for how it's gonna be themed
and how i'm gonna build the areas around
it so without further ado let's get into
that part of the video and see how we're
gonna dress this thing up
so as you might be able to tell from the
title of this video this coaster is
going to receive an arabian theming
specifically but i will go into this a
little bit later i'm going for a persian
inspired theme there are many types of
arabian and islamic architecture uh be
it the ancient well it's not ancient but
the old mamluk egyptian architecture or
moorish or mughal architecture from
the areas around modern day india these
are all slightly different styles with
their own interesting touches and
flourishes i think
but for this coaster specifically i'm
going for a persian inspired theme and
making that a little bit more broad
we could definitely think about persia
as it has been a long time ago when its
borders were somewhat larger than
nowadays
anyway i think uh architecture and
culture in general tends to not follow
state borders very specifically so when
i say persian i'm already gonna say that
i'm not an expert on these kinds of
things i just mean the general aesthetic
of that area which comes down to um some
specific touches that you'll see later
on but definitely onion domes then are
decorated in lavish mosaic tiles
wind catchers which are a very
particular part of persian architecture
that you find in modern day iran but
also united arab emirates and other
parts of the middle east things like
that which are gonna come into play here
and i might save the other
islamic architecture styles for other
parts of this little park here but
that's something i'm gonna go into later
anyway the title of this chapter is uh
somewhat inspired by the caliph stork
and i should
give you a quick warning that i'm going
to talk about fairy tales for the next
few minutes and not what i'm actually
building in planet coaster but trust me
this is going to be very relevant to
this coaster so for a while i had
decided on the coaster that i wanted to
build here and i had decided on the
theme and the theme as well is something
that i just wanted to try i've hardly
ever done any arabian inspired builds in
planet coaster and you don't see too
many of them either in general and i
think this has something to do with the
fact that there are very few arabian
pieces in the game there are
some moorish inspired elements i believe
they're from the vintage pack um but you
know they're not they are a little bit
orientalist i would say they're kind of
the western carnival inspired idea of
what moorish architecture would be and
while they can help somewhat with
arabian architecture in general i think
when you really want to get down into
the nitty-gritty and try to distinguish
between different flavors um it's it's
not going to be quite enough to to work
on that so you have to make all of the
pieces yourself is what it boils down to
so this is going to be a very time
consuming venture but it's also
something i really wanted to try because
it's something new you know i've done
enough alpine and japanese themes and
it's really fun to explore new things
anyway so this has an arabian theme i'd
already settled on that and this is a
dueling sns free fly coaster
and for hours i've been looking for a
name and a theme of this coaster and i
was coming up empty until a friend of
mine suggested the story of the caliph
stork now this is a story that i don't
know my heart very well but i'm gonna
try and tell it without spoiling the
ending by the way so if you're really
interested in old fairy tales you can
look this up yourself but the caliph
stork is a story about a caliph a ruler
of a caliphate in um
well what is nowadays
but was
probably imagined somewhat during the
abbasid era or the golden age of islam
when baghdad was the biggest city in the
world and a huge center for science and
art and all of that good stuff um but
yeah
i'm already getting sidetracked from
telling this story so we have this calif
we have this ruler of this area and his
um
what's it called again
vizier which is a sort of assistance to
the ruler of the caliph and he and this
guy have this magician
guy who
this is this is this is the worst
telling of a fairy tale ever but a
magician
tricked them
into using a magic spell to turn
themselves into storks and the story
goes that there's a magic word that they
can use to turn themselves back into
humans but if at any point during their
stork experience they laugh they forget
the magic word and they are forever
stuck being storks so what happens of
course these dorks they turn themselves
into storks and then something makes
them laugh and they forget the magic
word and turns out that it's all been a
ruse by the magician to get rid of the
old ruler and take over his land
so now these two storks are very sad and
flying through the land that they used
to rule looking for a way to turn back
into humans and uh save their land from
this this evil
so that's the story of the flying storks
and it just perfectly manages to fit
into this persian arabian theme that i
wanted to go for in this ride and not
just that
the
birds that you see on the free fly
coaster well i think they're supposed to
be crane birds because that's what tron
on in scara's summerland has
but to be very honest i think they kind
of look like storks as well they're
somewhere in between a crane and a stork
it feels like so for me at least i can
suspend this belief and recognize these
birds as being storks or the very like
at the very least very historic like so
i think that fits perfectly into the
theme and
it also gives me a very good excuse
to do some really interesting scenery
interactions between the coaster and
well all the things that you're seeing
me build here about which by the way the
first building that i built just on the
left on that tallest helix is a
minaret inspired tower i can definitely
see my kind of european castle
influences here and there in the way
that i'm laying out these buildings but
it is what it is the tower is also a bit
inspired by the national garden gate
entrance
in tehran in iran which is
a really cool building which has crazy
decorations on both sides of it but on
the inside on the garden side it has
these two towers on the sides which i
think worked pretty well and i pretty
much made it a little bit larger and
different to come up with this tower
it's still going to receive a roof at a
later date don't worry about it i was
procrastinating doing that during this
time because it was gonna be a little
bit too time consuming for my liking and
i wanted to finish the support
structures first
and then over here we have a typical
wind catcher which is something that you
see very often
in uh persia and
well all kinds of countries in that area
nowadays there are some cities in iran
which are famous for having lots of
these wind towers and they are used to
draw in cool air
uh and uh throw warm air out of the
buildings and they're basically uh
centuries old actually thousands of
years old way of climate controlling uh
buildings in the desert um because they
can help draw in cool air because
temperature swings in the desert are
quite extreme so you'll have very cold
nights super hot days and these towers
can help very sustainably to uh to cool
down buildings and maintain a nice
livable atmosphere so
that's that and also i think these two
structures work really well to hide the
support structure and this is part of
something that i really wanted to do
with this coaster and that is to see how
i could blend the theming aspects of
this coaster as much as possible with
the coaster experience itself and heck i
even think the story comes into play in
in this in some sense because the story
of the caliph stork is obviously this
kind of roaming the land that he used to
rule and um trying to find desperately
trying to find some way to to take back
his human form
and i imagine this torque frantically
flying through the city and all the
places that he used to know from a
different perspective
and i think that's the kind of a story
that this goes perfectly with so
without further ado i believe my next
chapter is meant to tell a little bit
more about the scenery and the ride
experience combination so
let's get to it
so when i was at disneyland paris my
favorite ride there is big thunder
mountain now
everybody can have their own opinions of
course i think phantom manor is a
beautiful ride in its own right and
space mountain
at least the original version especially
is wonderful but something that i really
love about big thunder mountain that
barely any coaster ever does
is its ride experience even its track
even its ride vehicles they all fit into
the theme and the story of the ride it's
a runaway mine train going haywire and
it's just complete immersion you know
how some roller coasters let's say for
instance um philosophy coaster it has an
amazing scenery
beautiful theming you really probably
because i haven't written velocicoaster
but i can imagine you feel very immersed
in the jurassic world
um
environment there but something that
just always irks me about coasters like
this is that the coaster track and the
coaster experience
is kind of separate from the theming
obviously when you ride velossa coaster
you're not riding an actual dinosaur and
you're aware that you're riding this
steel intamin beast and you're in a
coaster and
in your brain you can kind of shut off
that fact and just enjoy the coaster for
what it is and enjoy the scenery around
it for what it is as a beautiful setting
but
it's not a story that you can completely
move into you know um i think baron 1898
is a really good example as well it
tells the story of miners going down
into a cursed mine and you've got the
wailing
women i think it is i don't know exactly
it's been a it's been a while but um the
coaster is obviously not part of that
story it's used to tell the story but
it's not a part of it and that's
something that i think is beautiful
about big thunder mountain it's one of
those rare coaster experiences where the
ride experience itself
perfectly fits the theming and it just
becomes one
hole that becomes more than the sum of
its parts somehow and i think there are
some other coasters that do this really
well too
you've got hagrid's motorbike adventure
at universal islands of adventure which
obviously you're actually riding a
motorbike you've even got the little
smaller seats on the side and it really
looks like hagrid's motorbike which is
really cool and you've also got tron
light cycle run which in a very similar
theme uh has the setting of riding these
motorbikes in tron and it has the
computer simulated graphics as uh
scenery which is also one of these
experiences where the ride and the
theming melt into one
and being at disney riding big thunder
mountain just made me realize that this
is something that
i absolutely love and it's something
that i've never been able to explore in
planet coaster outside of obviously
building jaegerhorn where you
automatically get that same bonus of
being a mine train as big thunder
mountain has so
for a while i've been trying to come up
with some kind of coaster where you can
suit the right experience to a certain
theme and really try and make it blend
with the surrounding areas
and when it comes to the track
i think this is still not quite there
obviously you have to
imagine that the track is not there or
at least it's not part of the ride
experience itself but the vehicles that
you're sitting in the way that you fly
through these buildings all of that is
at least part of the story and it fits
the story of the caliph stork and it
fits the theming that we have around
here and i think it can make for a
unique ride experience that you don't
have anywhere else in real life at least
at the moment while at the same time
being heavily themed and i think this is
also extra fun because i've never seen a
heavily themed
sns freefly coaster being attempted
let alone a dueling one
so trying to do that as well is really
fun and makes for some new opportunities
for example
coming up with these towers as support
structures to hide the supports as much
as possible which is nice because it
makes the coaster look
a bit nicer but it's also one of these
ways where you can blend the technical
aspects of the coaster with the theming
surrounding it
and i'm no structural engineer so
honestly i don't know how realistic
these support structures are
but given that some coasters do this in
real life and you've got this on
water slides as well in fact the support
structures are very heavily inspired by
water slide structures
i think it's uh plausible
and i'm a little bit more
iffy about the uh structures that you
can see to support the zero g role there
which is actually a lighter fly element
but doesn't matter it's a it looks like
a zero g raw because it has a
really janky support in the middle of it
supporting both coasters and then some
track connectors connecting the two
tracks together which is something that
gerslauer coasters do very often but i
wasn't sure if it could work out with
this kind of coaster but that's why this
is a game i'm doing my best to make it
as believable as possible and make sure
that within uh some sort some form of
suspense of disbelief uh it's it's
probably possible but uh structural
engineers could probably tell me a
little bit more about how these supports
work out in general
that said
besides just trying to realistically
support this coaster
i had to come up with a way to make this
layout conducive to heavy theming around
it as well as you might be able to tell
the vehicles for the free fly coaster
are huge you've got these wide wingspans
and then you've got people sitting on
the sides of these wings in swinging
carriages which also means that the
swing adds to the hitbox that you have
for these things and um that's a lot of
space to worry about uh not building any
scenery in and on top of that this is a
dueling coaster so you've got two of
these massive hitboxes flying across the
track and basically giving you zones
where you cannot build any scenery
so
this is also part of the reason why i
wanted to be very careful about the
layouts and come up with the theming
along with the layouts because i had to
specifically make the layout in such a
way that there was space left over
to do scenery
so for these first two helixes for
instance
we have the coaster switching from an
upright position to a upside down
position after the first curve which
helps because during that first curve it
obviously rotates to a 90 degree angle
which gives me extra space to fit this
tower in the middle if i kept it banked
to the inside like a regular coaster
there would be no space for this tower
because one of the wings would smash
into it people would die and stuff it
wouldn't be very comfortable then after
that the carriage is upside down which
gives me space to build a bridge over it
and after that we move into another
helix to the right
where there's more space to fit a tower
which is where i built the wind catcher
and after that we move into a block
break section which doubles as a theming
aspect that crosses over the upside down
part of the first curve but it's also
just a nice bridge some theming to add
to this whole structure and make the
whole thing more dense and interesting
i also think it makes for really
interesting head choppers in general
this this ride gives opportunities for
really cool headshoppers because the
carriages on the side
with people in them are about as tall as
the bird in the middle so you can come
really close to scenery even taking into
consideration that the carriages are
swinging so you have to
give them some extra space and do some
really interesting things with that
so that's the uh that's the idea of
melting this ride experience together
with the theme and speaking of the theme
there are some things that i need to
note really quickly as i'm working on
the spire of the tower here you can see
some tiles that are from a theme maker's
toolkit
and this is probably worth talking about
i haven't used many theme makers toolkit
items in any of my builds in planet
coaster so far i've definitely used some
mostly in my ski resort videos
but it's something that i've strayed
away from doing too much in general and
for this build i'm trying to use as many
three makers toolkit items as i can
whenever i can and
the reason for that is
honestly i've been looking at the same
pieces and the same textures in planet
coaster for many years and i really
wanted to try something else make
something that looks different make
something that to me at least
is more refreshing and i don't think
this makes it easier per se i sometimes
see people
um reasoning that using tmaker's toolkit
makes it easier to make good looking
things or it's in some way cheating
personally i don't think so i think
there's a really interesting challenge
to limiting the amount of pieces that
you can use and definitely
limiting yourself to the original piece
of the game without any dlcs is a really
fun cool challenge to get creative with
pieces but in the end if you have a
vision for something that you want to
build in the game
i don't think it matters too much which
pieces you're using for that and if
you're using extra pieces that people
created for the game most of the theme
makers toolkit pieces are small they're
quite simple you still have to do a lot
of work yourself to turn them into
things that you want to do so for
instance most of the stucco pieces that
i'm using here are theme maker's toolkit
stucco pieces because i love the
textures and i think they work really
well for the theme some of the wood
pieces that i'm using are also theme
makers toolkit pieces but those wooden
pieces are just
similar logs and planks to the ones that
you have in game just with a different
shape or a different texture and
what's especially huge for this build
are the decal pieces mostly the decals
made by fururana
fua if you hear this thank you so much
for these amazing pieces because they
are a huge game changer and you see many
people using them these days
but yeah they're great because you can
use them to give these somewhat plain
simple stucco faces some detail and some
slight color changes especially around
the edges where you can add some cracks
or dirty grime stains and things like
that and it's small touches like this
which make builds feel a little bit more
realistic especially because real life
parks play with their stucco textures in
this way so all things considered i
think using teammaker's toolkit doesn't
necessarily make the game easier
it just gives you it just gives you more
options to turn your vision into a
reality with maybe some exceptions
obviously there will be three makers
toolkit pieces which are very large and
pre-built elements
but i'm really using the smaller pieces
here to give myself more flexibility and
options to
come up with a way to translate some
creative vision in my head to something
in the game
and i came up with this rant because the
roof of the tower is made up of very
small thememakers toolkit bricks
which work really well as roof shingles
or as bricks if you're making a custom
brick wall and these are the kind of
pieces that otherwise i would have just
used small wooden brackets for in the
game but then i'd end up with way too
many polygons and textures that don't
quite suit the need
and with these smaller theme makers
toolkit pieces there's just more
flexibility so
i think it's great and i really enjoyed
playing with it
there's also another thing that i want
to note while i'm working on this small
minaret that's beside the lift hill and
that is that the wind catcher that i
built is unfinished i built these wind
catchers and then i realized later on
wait a second i forgot about the
interior of these things because
generally the way they work is that they
have different holes that are separated
from each other
that can be inlets and outlets at any
time it depends on the wind direction so
for instance if a town has a prevailing
wind direction or a prevailing good wind
direction where the wind isn't dusty or
whatever it will have open holes on both
sides of the wind catcher but not on the
other one whereas if a town has many
directions that the wind could possibly
be coming from you've got
omnidirectional wind catchers which are
the ones that i'm working on right now
they've got holes on all sides
and you can let the air go in or out on
uh whatever side would be necessary
depending on what the wind direction is
only problem is i um
managed to build these things without
actually closing them on the inside so
all the winds just gonna go straight
through this and not actually down into
the towers
uh really sorry about this guys this is
not gonna be fixed for the next few
episodes because i already have a bunch
of stuff recorded
in um in advance and also i'm not gonna
come back to these very soon but just
know that eventually i will go back to
the wind catchers and fix these things
up for now though you'll just have to uh
you'll just have to suffer in pain uh
looking at these things anytime i hope
it's not going to be too bad just know
that i'm here with you guys and i'm
still annoyed at my old self for
leaving these things like this
anyway that's the wind catchers i'm also
going to try and make all the wind
catches slightly unique they have a very
typical design with these um
well four
actually that's that's eight yeah with
eight pillars
uh which means you basically get eight
holes and then they always have these
logs
lodged into them um so it's a very
typical look you also have
wind catchers that look different some
of them won't have planks or um there
are some octa
there are some octagon shaped
wind catches as well but these are the
most typical ones and the ones i figured
i wanted to use for this build and here
i started working on a minarets which
i end up throwing away
at a later stage so sorry about that i'm
gonna try and come up with a way to
bring this thing back at some point in
the future uh just know for now that i
really love experimenting with smaller
scenery elements but you can only
see what the complete picture looks like
once you finish that smaller scenery
element and sometimes
things just kind of don't work out
which is also a bit of a shame because
this minaret ended up taking a lot of
time to build just like the other one
but it's i don't know i just really
enjoy doing these things and placing
lots of items on spires and
seeing what kind of shapes you can
possibly come up with but i'm going to
leave it at that point this thing is
going to come back at some point in the
future but
don't want to dwell on it too much at
this point
now i saved the least for last in this
because i was procrastinating on doing
the back sides of these buildings
because yeah for the way it feels these
buildings really do have some backsides
in the middle here
and this is a kind of
unfortunate circumstance because of the
way that these layouts are built but in
the middle here we just have a mess of
buildings that i have to finish and make
look decent but it's obviously never
going to be a
a very big important part of this ride
although that's also worth mentioning i
think whenever you're doing scenery you
have to also build scenery that you know
barely anybody is going to look at and
that you want to keep out of the view
most of the time or at least not draw
any attention to because as humans
there's no way that we can
throw all our attention at an entire row
of buildings or facades and have it work
out very well typically it's always good
to try and come up with certain
perspectives or parts of buildings that
you really want to bring most of the
attention to and finish the rest as a
way to give context to those buildings
but not draw the eye of people too much
to it so in this case the tower is going
to be the main interest point and the
layouts themselves but this is really
filler and i think that's fine but yeah
that is it for this episode i hope you
guys enjoyed it and are just excited to
see how this pans out as i am because at
this point in time i'm still also very
curious but
let me know what you think of it and for
now thanks for watching and hope you
guys have a good day and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you